tenemos la ecuación de 2 es igual a
menos 2 que multiplican a x menos 3 y lo
que quiero averiguar es cuál es la
pendiente de la recta de esta ecuación
ahora hay un par de formas con las que
puedes encontrar está pendiente la
primera es pensar bueno ya que conocemos
algunas formas de escribir la ecuación
en donde es fácil encontrar la pendiente
por ejemplo podemos manipular esta
ecuación y llegar a la forma de igual a
mx más bien y aquí ya sabemos que m es
decir el coeficiente en el término x es
nuestra pendiente y bueno b es nuestra
intersección con el eje y ahora otra
opción es escribir esta ecuación en la
forma punto pendiente donde su forma es
la siguiente si tengo james menos 1
igual a m por x menos x 1 entonces aquí
puedes ver que la recta tiene una
pendiente de m
y bueno tal vez te salte dónde está la
intersección con el eje james pero
podemos encontrarla ya que nos dan un
punto en esta recta ya que sabemos que
el punto x 11 está en la recta así que
vamos a regresar a nuestro ejercicio y
lo primero que nos debe de saltar es que
bueno observa aquí tenemos x menos 3 y
por acá tenemos este menos 2 así que
este menos 2 representa la pendiente y
de hecho esto responde a la pregunta
pero bueno tal vez digas es que esperan
acá tengo un +2 y después de tener menos
de 1 pero no hay por qué preocuparse
podemos escribir esta ecuación como
james menos -2 igual a menos 2 que
multiplican a x menos 3 y observa que
estamos en la forma punto pendiente
puedes ver que aquí claramente se ve que
mi pendientes menos 2 ahora si te
pedirán a no se me llame un punto que
esté en esta recta entonces muy
fácilmente tú me vas a decir ok tenemos
el punto x
a tres de igual a menos dos el punto 3 -
2 ese punto vive en la recta ojo no
tenemos de una manera explícita nuestra
intersección con el eje james pero de
una manera muy sencilla podemos
encontrarla ya que tenemos un punto y
una pendiente y es más vamos a hacerlo
porque la otra forma de obtener la
pendiente sería simplemente manipular
esta ecuación hasta obtener la ecuación
de la forma y la mx más p así que
hagámoslo lo primero que se me ocurre es
distribuir este menos 2 y si lo hago voy
a obtener yemas 2 igual a menos 2 por x
lo cual me dan menos 2x y después tengo
menos 2 x menos 3 lo cual es más 6 y
después puede restar 2 de ambos lados
estos dos se cancelan y así voy a
obtener james igual a menos 2x
4 y observa aquí ya estamos en la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen y una vez
más puedes ver que claramente mi
pendiente es menos 2 así que todo en
orden mejor vamos a hacer otro ejemplo y
lo voy a poner por acá tengo esta
ecuación y bueno observa que no la tengo
escrita en ninguna de estas dos formas
así que vamos a manipularla y pasarla a
la forma pendiente ordenada al origen ya
que va a ser más fácil pasarla a esa
forma entonces hagámoslo qué te parece
si despejamos allá y bueno vamos a sumar
tres de ambos lados 3 del lado izquierdo
y 3 del lado derecho y así vamos a
eliminar este menos 3 y me queda en este
lado izquierdo menos 4 x más 10 y en el
lado derecho
simplemente 2 james y ahora para
despejar ayer tenemos que dividir de
ambos lados por 2
entonces si dividimos todo por 2 tengo
menos 2 x 5 igual am bien y esto ya está
en la forma pendiente ordenada al origen
tal vez tenga la aie a la derecha pero
realmente es lo mismo entonces si tengo
la forma que iguala mx más ven ya puedo
decir que m es decir la pendiente que es
el coeficiente del término x va a ser
otra vez menos 2 y bueno en este caso la
ordenada al origen vale 5 más si
queremos saberlo muy bien ya que
agarramos un poco más de práctica vamos
a hacer un último ejercicio este de aquí
ahora tengo esta ecuación que observa de
nuevo no está en una forma conocida y
bueno vamos a trabajarla para llevar
esta ecuación a la forma que igual a mx
+ b y esta vez como siempre te voy a
decir pausa el vídeo y ver si puedes
obtener la pendiente que buscamos
ok vamos a dejar solo el ayer de un lado
de la ecuación y a las x del otro lado
entonces qué te parece si quitamos este
menos 3x del lado izquierdo y para eso
hay que sumar 3 x de ambos lados y para
quitar este 3 sep del lado derecho
que te parece si restamos 3 james de
ambos lados y bueno si hago esto voy a
obtener aquí tengo menos 3 x 3 x se
cancelan recuerdan lo que hago de un
lado lo voy a hacer del otro para que
así se mantengan mi igualdad entonces
estos dos se cancelan y me quedaría
simplemente 5 james menos 3 james lo
cual es 2 james y bueno aquí en el lado
derecho observa tengo 2 x 3 x lo cual es
5 x en estos dos se van a cancelar y si
ahora lo que queremos es despejar aiem
entonces hay que dividir todo x
y así voy a obtener quién es igual a 5
medios de equis y ya está aunque tal vez
digas oye pero esto no se ve exactamente
de la forma pendiente ordenada al origen
donde esta vez pero aquí en este caso
obtuve vale 0 5 medios de x + 0 si así
lo quieres ver y por lo tanto ya podemos
ver de una manera muy clara que la
pendiente que es el coeficiente del
término x va a ser igual a 5 medios y
bueno vemos es igual a 0 porque cuando
ex vale 0 quien va a valer también 0